[Music]
[Applause]
306 in Vancouver
that's right welcome back to the break
room it's our daily live show that keeps
you updated on all the nerdy fandom news
you need to know hey what time is it
where you are right now
don't encourage him hey it's coming up
on the break room today the Planet of
the Apes is gonna be coming back I
messed that headline I'm sorry uh hey
don't say sorry to me I don't know who
wrote this [ __ ] is Ned about to break
bad yeah that was good stay out of my
territory uh and we can't drag ourselves
away from the Deadpool news it is just a
tasty chimichanga that we'll keep eating
everyone is saying what time it is where
they are and God bless you all hey we
got so much more to talk about today on
the breaker but first i'm Brandon who
cares across the table we got koi
Chandra oh there's six in Vancouver
excited to be here in Vancouver live in
Vancouver thank you so much and next to
him we have Anna vanston despite knowing
that PSL doesn't stand for or pumpkin
sucking lips my brain always freaks out
when I see it why do you think pumpkin
smells sucking her lips oh because DSM I
got there I got there that's an internet
connection I like that leap I'm with you
speaking of pumpkin sucking lips
hey never met a pumpkin that left
unsatisfied I am the Great Pumpkin
sucker
oh my God oh my God we're deep fists and
pumpkins here in the break room today
it's too early I'm back on the apps
folks I'm a double gourd math kind of
guy find me on Bumble find me on what he
goes deep chord it's too early it's too
early Into The Fall season yeah I'm on
border to accept that PSL standards and
I'm gonna see pumpkin spice very
arousing um I'm gonna walk into
Starbucks
oh this show is chuggy
no one's ever heard of [ __ ] they've only
ever seen it written uh that's cap and
hey if you feel like it said in those
super chats today we'd love to get to as
many as many of those super chats as we
can we've already got one from John
Dunham who said would be funny in
Deadpool 3 Deadpool makes a joke like
actually huh we might need you one more
time after this see you in secret Wars
coming up he had a lot of interjections
in there like these are he was really
writing the dialogue thank you so much
John John I think I'm at Hugh not huh
I read it wrong yeah I just want to give
John Dunham the credit union reserves
because we're not going to bury the
Trashy Chatters before they deserve it
and many of them do Pat mcgorry double
he's five trash bag Paul mcgoy Paul
McCartney fine trash bins I don't
believe it I've sucked too many pumpkins
today and it's going to my head uh Hey
speaking of head we got headlines
pumpkin suckers in the chat skip over
the back that you said heads multiple
times okay all right
Tom the pumpkin sucker you're gonna get
demonetized known on the break room as
the sickest mother trucker oh beautiful
thank you uh we have breaking news this
has been a week of breaking news we
can't get the show started in time
Marvel has announced via The Hollywood
Reporter that the upcoming armor War
series that we didn't know if they were
still gonna do but then they promised
they're gonna do it is now going to be a
film
according to the highway reporter the
move essentially pushes back the title
further down the development slate
didn't they just say that armor was tied
directly into secret Invasion yes
[Music]
how does it move how does it move if
it's a piece of a puzzle they're like no
longer a corner well we do know that
Marvel they had to shift around like a
Multiverse of Madness yeah and see a lot
with no way home so they can move it I
hope this isn't getting the Rogue
Squadron treatment where they just keep
putting it off until eventually don't
worry about it we're sending armor Wars
to a farm in Maine where it can run free
I'm looking forward to our Andor special
at the end of this episode oh baby we're
gonna talk so much today uh I I do feel
like this is maybe a revenge for Don
Cheadle being like hey Mike contracts up
I can do whatever I want Kevin he's like
you think your contract's up I can hold
on to this movie you owe us one more
you're in development yeah for an
extended period of time seven years of
him waiting War Machine one last time
looking at the Terence Howard one more
time baby now it's his meme yeah a lot
of these shows have felt like you know
movies broken into six episodes or
something like that so I think it'll be
good you know I'm excited no matter what
armor is the [ __ ] story and Don
Cheadle is an incredible actor and I'm
sure the writing is exceptional but it's
really weird that they could be like it
ties directly into TBD something in the
sleep they got all those empty spots in
phase six they can fit him in there
Deadpool armor sources also said the
studio was committed and getting the
story told the right way and that the
process realized that a feature was
better suited no pun intended for the
project I I do have this means like a
little more money for our former suits
that look cool to me this sounds like a
budget thing where they looked at the
story they were trying to tell realized
it could be a three-hour show at X
budget or could be a two-hour movie with
XX budget and I think that that's a
smarter move I think I think over the
next five years we're gonna see a lot
more things that were green lit as long
form become short form because of the
Fallout of Disney discount uh Disney's
Disney plus stuff and Discovery
acquiring WB I think we're gonna see a
shift back towards film because of Top
Gun and some things I think there is a
higher profit sustainability in film
because at the end of the day if seven
people are staring a seven dollar
Subscription Service you're not making
money yeah and I think if you're making
them like armor Wars you need that money
like 200 million dollar suit budget I
feel like in general people take the
films more seriously yeah TV show more
gravitas yeah
you sit down you're at the movie theater
you're with your friends the lights go
down it's not like in the background
while you're doing like Yahtzee and you
have to consume pretty much you have to
consume them all but in one chunk unless
you walk out I'll make this move I'll be
back tomorrow I'll leave this movie I
saw Top Gun in theaters and it cost me
300 yeah have you seen it ten times no
no one code oh dude I'm so sorry no no
I'm just I'm just that was an old man
rant about ticket prices yeah I'm not an
old man I was born in 2000 yeah you're
the youngest person on the break room
and I will say when I do my cam shows
they're not as popular as when I release
my feature films
especially when pumpkins are involved I
don't want to talk anymore health and
today hey 20th Century Fox has announced
that the next Planet of the Apes film is
going to be called Kingdom of the Planet
of the Apes it's being directed by Maze
Runner directed West ball uh and it's
going to have Owen Teague Freya Allen
and Peter Macon to start they're setting
it for a 2024 release which is pretty
pretty pretty ambitious I hope Andy
Circus Comes Back My question is
yeah if you haven't watched if you've
never saw the like most recent Planet of
the Apes trilogy spoilers for five years
ago seven years it's also great it's
really good it's really incredible
that's really just one of the best the
Tim Burton one is interesting on its own
if you want to watch that for a real
wild ride yeah as a I I'm a young man
but my father always really likes the
original plane of the Apes movies have
you seen anything does it doesn't it
look like I've seen all
we should do our version of like the
people reacting enthusiastically on Tick
Tock while Anna explains we're like
uh-huh oh fry ties
where do you get it from the source
material yeah
uh next headline hey speaking about his
uh becoming role as sci-fi's Reginald
the vampire on house beautiful's dark
house podcast Jacob battle on was asked
if he would ever consider playing
villains going forward he said quote I
feel like as an actor I really
gravitated more towards really dark
dramatic things as opposed to Comedy and
things of that nature but I found you
know playing Ned and Reginald it has
sort of given me this light where I
wasn't seeing things so negatively and I
wasn't thinking so deeply or Darkly
about things Ned are you okay yeah okay
uh he feels like I'm looking forward to
doing a lot of other things which you
know many people may not see me doing
right now dark Ned wow really really
avoiding the question as much as he is
still saying so much I mean who wouldn't
want to be
quietly dropping that he went to drama
school oh yeah I appreciate it I'm an
actor
myself an actor there's nothing wrong
with that you know I was ashamed for a
long time but now I refer to myself as
an actor yeah if you're a pumpkin sucker
call yourself a pumpkin sucker do what
you gotta do know thyself are you I do
hang around the pumpkin patch quite a
bit honestly if we're being honest All
actors eventually become pumpkin suckers
it is true as my good friend Polonius
once said this above all to thine own
self be true next headline
comicbook.com's Chris Killian recently
got the chance to talk with Guy Pierce
and he revealed that he's eager to
return to the MCU as Audrey Killian if
they ever reach out to him you say eager
I say he's playing hard to guess
John might be joking back there but the
switch is still running all right good
he's switching cameras he's uh what he's
asked about this guy Pierce said uh no
if he had considered me or Marvel had
reached out for him to play Aldrich
Killian again he said no I haven't heard
from them actually I suppose I've just
written off the idea because of what
happened to Aldridge Killian at the end
of Iron Man 3 but at the same time
within those worlds kind of anything is
possible and yet I still haven't
received a car from a call from anyone
at Marvel no car either no cars
no Cardinals uh so I'm not sure if it's
in the works but who knows uh I I you
know I think that would be a fun
character come back if you haven't
Revisited Iron Man 3. it's a fun little
Shane black romp but Guy Pierce is great
isn't it he plays a great fire and I
don't know if I can forgive him for that
reasons
watch the other things he's so much
better I like his like little dirty
version I like his sexy I'm gonna steal
your pepper pots yes Mr steal your pots
Mr steal your pots ESL yeah
second list
I was most mad at that movie that they
gave pepper the powers and then Tony
takes them away I mean because she might
die I guess but she seemed like she was
fine she was good she would have been
awesome yeah yeah uh that's true I feel
like Tony gave those Powers away and
then I promoter took them away
tell women they can do things do not let
them know I liked it better when she was
taking notes put them back in the office
bring back secretary
and by the way does black widow have to
be good at fighting because she also
just be taking notes but instead of this
woman who's clearly been set up to be
the villain is replaced by this guy who
had a little breeze fire
promoter if you're watching right now
and you're crying come on Michelle who's
a servant come on the break Stephen come
on the show if you've got thoughts about
how pepper pots and Elder Killian should
ship themselves into a future
relationship come join us sure yeah I
mean Audrey should show up now that
Tony's gone I think he's dead he's an
armed Wars that's why it's a movie now
I hope he still got his regular head
he's still growing a new body and it's
just like wet Roots wet flesh Roots
you mean like a pumpkin root yeah yeah
like he's just growing in the patch he's
just growing in the patch uh here's
another interesting casting headline so
Jeff Schneider who's been really popping
off this week former senior film credit
at collider he put out this tweet today
from a podcast he had uh today or
yesterday where he was talking about
apparently he's reporting that Marvel is
gonna bring in Harrison Ford to the
Thunderbolts movie why are you laughing
at me
John doesn't like how it will not get
into this John's watching episodes of
Frasier back taking another break listen
if you want I'll handle this I know
you're uncomfortable I don't dance
around it Schneider you know he used to
work at collider with Johnny Campisi
it's reporting Harrison Ford might have
been in talks play Thunderbolt Ross in
the upcoming Thunderbolts movie this is
what the rumor he reported on the hot
mics podcast was was that they were
actually ready to announce this at d23
but Kathleen K said no no no no no my
friends This is Indiana Jones's time you
are not taking this away from lucasfilms
a subsidiary of the Disney Corporation
fighting go buy Yee okay you're not
announcing it so now the speculation is
because that moment passed Ford may have
lost interest he may have already turned
it down he may be in negotiations I know
personally he's shooting the uh
Yellowstone prequel 1923 in Montana
right now and I believe after I mean I
think he did he did a movie before that
he may want a little bit of a break so
unless the role of Thunderbolt Ross is a
glorified cameo
I don't know that we could put a lot of
stock in this however they did bring up
another name in that podcast that I
liked which was Kevin freaking Costner
as Thunderbolt Ross and I say why not
give it to the cost man well and I also
think
I'm wondering if this like his idea to
play Thunderbolt Ross is more like the
idea is that he would replace the
character of Thunderbolt rock with a new
character right that fits that same
general lightning strike Jones yes I
mean they have recast uh actors as
different characters in the MCU I don't
I don't know if anyone's if their whole
plan was like we need Thunderbolt Ross
to become Red Hulk that's how it is in
the comics that's how we're gonna do it
yeah they don't have to do that I don't
think anyone's gonna be super mad I
don't know it just seems weird is that
original is that original actor of
deceased yeah he did William Hurt did
pass who played he was great and we were
all super hyped for him to be red Hulk
especially when he came back after like
eight years yeah yeah like he was gone
because he was in the non-marvel he was
in the fox uh Hulk movie and everyone
was like well we'll never see him again
and then he came back
and then got him like Nelson in two
weeks yeah yeah like Tim like Nelson
coming back also where's Betty Ross I
mean Tyler hanging out singing songs
with her dad I like to think Deadpool
snuck in and stole her away
yeah I like that for him I like that for
him uh see Lulu is Harrison Ford going
to be and Thunderbolts come on the show
me three he couldn't talk to Harrison oh
baby
we got some new images from werewolf
finite via Reddit let's take a look at
these these bad boys so black and white
so sulking that's like what my eyes look
like in the morning oh I mean I haven't
seen this yet koi has seen it I've seen
it we know Eric bosses from I think
there's a social thing I think you're
okay to have a social uh uh talk so I
will say about the length of one tweet
amongst My Favorite Things in phase four
by a comfortable margin and that it
excels at exactly what it strives to be
and more
258 characters so close so close it's
exceptional it's such a special property
and it reminded me of what I love about
Marvel it's it's really really unique
better than eternals for koi foreign
for me it's no way home
um Loki season two this and then shung
chin eternals oh my goodness
but okay it's about separate it's so
good well this is like all-time QB like
do you want cookie dough or like
vegetables right so like it's the cookie
dough I want more beef
you might want the vegetables it's the
steamed artichokes that film oh my God
okay
Jesus asls and other things
it's a very different [ __ ] he's
assassins here's another headline for
you uh we were introduced to another
mutant on last night's She-Hulk El
iguila making his debut his power being
referred to as bio electricity boy it
wouldn't even drop a spoiler warning we
just went for hey if you haven't watched
She-Hulk get with the program on also
you knew he was going to be yeah because
he was in the Jesus also I don't
remember if man is it man bull man bull
if he was a mutant in the comics no
because they make a point in the show
and saying that it was an accident and
then another and another spoiler and a
port the perkola pie the Portola pie is
he a mutant well and we're talking
strictly the stinky man okay he's
definitely got an odor too yeah I was
real bummed that they waist porcupine
man I love that character a waste he's
not done yet I want more
that's it he's the only one because he's
not an Avenger they're gonna use they're
gonna use Ant-Man he's going to shrink
down porcupine shove him up king's butt
Grom and the spikes will come the spikes
will get away
just like an anchor uh match 143 sending
in a Super Chat saying bring the break
room actually up here to Vancouver BC
you cowards sorry also hi Anna hi nice
we are actually in Vancouver come find
us yeah we're over on uh uh uh Maple
we're at the corner of Maple and Oak at
MC Pines Sugar Shack there's a Tim
Hortons across the streets
near the mountain station
Ryan Reynolds we're free basing birthday
cake Timbits right now they're so good
ooh that was a deep kind of like that
next deadline in an interview with
Entertainment Tonight on the red carpet
I don't know which red carpet what what
of many Elizabeth Olsen says there are
no plans for Scarlet Witch to appear in
Agatha Covenant of chaos which means she
will definitely appear yeah
I you know what it's my fault it was the
red carpet for the varieties women of
power Advantage as the Scribe of today's
script I take full responsibility for
not adding that detail in but also
whenever someone says not a firm no but
that there are no plans as of this time
I say you can you can move the odds up
to 80 20. yeah then it's happening it
goes from like 50 50 or even less to
like it's almost definitely happening
the the answer that there are no firm
answers implies the answer is yes
exactly I hope it's like yeah it's
Agatha she's at the grave site uh for
for Wanda maximoffish she's crying and
then Val shows up she's crying she has
that she has an iPad and she's like this
is the man that killed yeah this is also
Hawkeye
everyone after Hawkeye I don't think
it's right next to Natasha's grave in
Ohio for no reason and it's just like it
doesn't make any the weirdest Avengers
right she's just got iPads
that could be a thirsty
thespians I mean we definitely could put
uh we we kind of let Guy Pierce off
though
well it wasn't thirsty it wasn't like he
did say he would like to come back but
he was also like I haven't heard a call
so they've probably written it off it
was kind of like I could have it I don't
care I could have a drink or two okay
I'm listening thank you Brain Stew for
that uh generous Super Chat also Emerson
white coming in with two back-to-back
Super chats that's an inner kick
internet connection Works two ways baby
guess who else Works two ways your boy
ah Emerson White Planet of the Apes
musical is the best installment in the
series that's for sure Emerson
back-to-back bangers in the Super Chat I
hate every ape I see from chimpanzee
yeah great stuff great stuff next
headline oh wait oh on the on the same
red carpet for varieties of women get
there or is it variety's power of women
or women of power it's powerful women
have powers that's power like the power
power women it's the power of women
uh it was on the same red carpet where
no one can tell a lie that uh Elizabeth
Olsen apparently first learned that Hugh
Jackman was coming to the MCU check your
tweets Elizabeth can I check in the
headlines come on
she doesn't live in her life she said
quote I guess Wolverine is X-Men
uh let me read it let me read it this
way okay you did it wrong I'll do this
quote since I'm being massacred in these
headlines
all right so you be you be the woman
from entertainment
um okay Entertainment Weekly and I'll be
Elizabeth Olsen Lizzy Lizzy Lizzy yeah
don't call her excuse me don't call her
that thank you now you're mean now
you're mean
everyone calls her Lizzy Lizzy uh-huh
what was the question did you hear that
Hugh Jackman is coming back uh in
Deadpool as an X-Men
are you [ __ ] kidding me don't say
[ __ ] I guess Wolverine is X-Men
it would be cool to work with a lot of
those people from the X-Men franchise I
guess Fassbender is my dad in some world
I don't know I'm a very relatable actor
anymore
I guess we'll bring the X-Men I guess
uh I do like I like her agency though of
being like if you're an expert you gotta
talk to me that's right you work with me
no more mutants no more I'd like to know
more mutants if you know what I mean so
that's I'm still a character
speaking of staying in character you
know how I keep Juiced up every day
my current everything my lords my
saviors coffee cult who sponsored last
week's She-Hulk breakdown and we've been
enjoying this delicious delicious coffee
in the office coffee cult is the closest
you can get to roasting your own coffee
beans without actually growing and
roasting your own Beans Coffee cough
source is only specialty grade arabica
beans from all over the world they
worked with the farmers to ensure the
best quality possible they inspect
affect every single beam so they're
never roasting anything that's less than
excellent
yes thank you I love it coffee called
not only roasts their own beans but they
roast it to order
it's hot it's kidding it's not it's been
sitting forever meaning that when you
get your coffee from coffee those beans
have been roasted fresh and it's
delicious trust me they've got all sorts
of different coffees you can check out
including exotic choices like Sumatra
which has notes of chocolate and brown
sugar just like me it is so much that
it's so much better than your average
cup of coffee to try coffee call for
yourself go to coffeecup.com and put in
promo code new rockstars10 to get 10 off
your order ordered more than 50 dollars
worth of coffee and they're gonna ship
that for free too free shipping again
that's coffeecult.com use promo order
promo code new rockstars 10 for 10 off
your order it helps us it helps you get
this sweet sweet coffee baby I liked
that five second bit where you were
silent while you were pretending to
drink it then said the product was too
scalding and it said it was ice cold
well they don't they don't send it hot
or cold
they send it to you in the beans we
roasted some of these beans in the other
bag that's open I chilled it because I'm
a little baby boy that gets too hot in
the lips too hot in the hips
I'm still helping out the coffee pot
here okay because I'm a member they make
us wear special outfits it's really
weird but I like it I like belonging to
something if coffee call it has to be my
destiny so be it I'm a coffee caulk guy
I've always been a coffee cult guy look
at the cup look at this mug
if you were going to be in a cult Tommy
I want you in the coffee club for sure
sure we're getting dangerously close
since coffee cult starts with a KK and
we're talking about nothing
he's got a sink very important gotta see
ah brainstorm also wanted to clarify a
previous Super Chat by saying he was
just explaining that he's thirsty for
the break room oh
we're thirsty for you or just the
concept of the bridge
also uh house at wrong town said in a
Super Chat saying love to see Huey Lewis
in the news references I'm not familiar
with that band myself being born in
2002. but uh my dad loves them my dad
loves them uh don't need money
just need discussions yes that's right
Tommy we just need discussions let's
break into that first discussion today
so like we've been saying we're so hyped
around this Deadpool news Coy hasn't
taken off his Deadpool shirts
it still smells pretty good when you're
using Dr Squatch not a sponsor are those
like the green you put in a chalupa yeah
okay
I stayed there today all day that's my
secret cap I'm always very nice mucho
mucho gusto uh well we've been chatting
a lot around the office about how like
Deadpool and Wolverine are just gonna
how they're gonna get into like the 616
uh MCU and most recently in Multiverse
of Madness of course Marvel they sort of
implied that the fox X-Men films are
maybe set in the earth 838 kind of
universe I don't know uh Professor X has
that line in the film that he says the
Multiverse Advantage where he's like
just because someone stumbles and loses
their way doesn't mean they lost forever
he said that to his younger self and and
X-Men Days of Future Past now maybe this
is just something that like all the
Charles Xavier say at one point in your
life this is their like with great power
comes great responsibility yes because
like to me this is another thing I was
confused about the 838 Universe are they
at the same time as the 616 is it the
year 2025 in that Universe when Dr
Strange and them go over it's so much
more futuristic yeah but this is also
like a utopian world with uh yeah
there's green growing everywhere maybe
Reed Richards is so smart that he's able
to fix the world yeah like the things
Tony couldn't right like he made old
front Bots that function yeah and so
those things might have accelerated I
think and I think the fact that street
honestly like that they're still Street
vendors implies that it's not super I
mean he still was he was running a
traditional food cart right like it
wasn't like he was like Hydro processing
it like Back to the Future too we'll
keep doing better future references
the future two in our own timeline that
sounds haunted yeah I love that uh
movies they kept making was fast and
furious little did we know that was the
real danger out there that movie is
about family it's not how you want it to
be that's true family getting eaten
alive some of those family members did
disappear let's keep going uh
even if like they're not from this A3
like the X-Men franchise that we know
right it exists in a different Universe
like somewhere out there
um my thing is like with Deadpool you
have this character who breaks the
fourth wall is like hyper aware almost
like omniscient I would say about what
other characters are doing or thinking
and things like that it makes me wonder
could Deadpool be like this Nexus being
where there's only one one breaking the
fourth wall Deadpool out there and they
just travel around well and he's stuck
in whatever Universe he's stuck in
because he's kind of connected to the
X-Men Universe right but not fully right
because the because he's able he
interacts with has like uh Colossus yes
but also has like uh negasonic teenagers
he's also able to reference both xaviors
right and he's also able to point out
that there's one room with these X-Men
in it and then he also is able to
reference yeah yeah and there's a
different Colossus in the fox X-Men
universe
who changes back and forth from fleshy
Colossus to garage door Colossus
well there's a metal version well we
also have garage door Anna and she's
great I hate her
she's so nice
where's garage door
but I like this idea that Deadpool the
Deadpool we've seen in the movies is the
only one and like every other version of
Wade Wilson or even Deadpool is not it's
a guy yeah he's not a guy that can break
the fourth wall and stuff like that he's
like what we saw in Wolverine Origins
right that eventually gets killed right
by the Deadpool that can transverse
universes what if our Deadpool are our
Nexus being Deadpool goes through
continuity at the end of Deadpool 2 and
when he's fixing continuity he's just
taking it under the Deadpools oh to like
so he's like yeah
and he hunts down the Green Lantern run
Reynolds he hunts down the head pull
from from X-Men Origins yeah so what if
he's that's his through line he's like
trying to be the Deadpool I do like that
because it makes me think that there's
not a dead pool in the 616 at all and
there's like not a Deadpool in the 838
at all or there's a Wade Wilson or
whatever so what I think they're doing
with this movie is they're gonna clean
the fox continuity with with Deadpool
kills the fox Universe because there's
an iconic comic called Deadpool kills
the Marvel Universe which is the number
one selling Deadpool comic of all time
it's a it's a logical thing to adapt but
instead of him killing the Marvel
character characters that you have you
know Chris Evans show up and flame on
and you kill Chris Evans as human torch
and you have Michael Jordan
um
he's just slicing them all in exactly so
you take out the fox Universe we've
established and that way when it folds
in you introduce New Mutants this movie
comes out in September 2024. it is three
months before the 2025 start of what I
think the X-Men are coming it's the
movie that follows Thunderbolts great
post-credit seem to have Deadpool in
he's been a thunderbolt it proceeds
Fantastic Four what if he just murks all
the old Fantastic Four setting up
fantastic and now it is technically the
first movie in phase six because there
was a blank slate in the phase six slot
so now Deadpool could launch all of this
stuff I think he should kill the fox
universe and he could be hunting all
those things and then Wolverine isn't
Logan Wolverine because you don't want
to mess that continuity we don't we
don't want X-Men origins of Wolverine
what if he's going around taking out Fox
characters comes upon the one that is
most identifiable Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine Wally's mowing down Fox and
then when he folds into Marvel the
reason he could break the fourth wall no
one else can except she able to figure
out the reason he's already the reason
he's gonna get bleeped is because he's
actually from Outsider continuity
consciously so while he's going around
mercury in the fox Universe when he
folds into the MCU it's a known removal
from our reality therefore making him a
Nexus being hopping back I think that's
how you solve all these arguments over
who's going to get cast as the Fantastic
Four you keep introducing them in movies
we're taping this on a Tuesday so we
don't know what's gonna happen by sorry
I just saw another two people's success
this was recorded nothing's funny do you
know how much easier our jobs would be
if we just banked these all on a Monday
but these news stories just go on the
internet these news stories come out the
day that we report them
pre-recorded my ass and by the way my
ass is pre-recorded on the internet so
Google it uh I do love you thank you
thank you Tommy uh I do love you
bringing up She-Hulk and her ability to
break the fourth wall uh because I do
want to scene where they're both talking
to the audience with their backs to each
other and then they but who are you
talking to who are you talking to 16
walls but we did see in She-Hulk the the
infamous po not post credits but credits
drawing scene right with all the shoes
that reference all these other Marvel
characters and one of them was Deadpool
and one of them was like Wolverine I
mean is it possible could they pull a
Ryan Reynolds Cameo comment that they
would love to do a Deadpool shooting
crossover so they're ready they're
willing
and you know uh our boy Hugh Jackman
he's still wrapping up music his run on
music man he's still there in New York
but he went and shot these things with
Ryan presumably in Canada somewhere uh
he could have bumped over before I don't
know when they shot she hoped
necessarily but it might have been right
before the show went up on Broadway or
he could have just come out for the
weekend or something they could grain
screen him in yeah
it was shot in the same house they shot
the Taylor Swift music video because
Ryan and Taylor Swift are homies so
there's a little T Swift is that Ryan's
house or is that just like a house
maybe Taylor just shot a video at
property Ryan Reynold Jones and he
kicked the family out for a week just
like it's my house he was here Jessica
wants to know if you can auction off all
her belongings oh yeah I got you the the
the bitter I'm ready Jess whatever
spinner who's bought everything and it's
me are we selling off are we selling off
Jess's belongings as needed
I think I think what would be really
funny uh to me is if the part of the
Deadpool movie was him collecting other
Deadpools and like kind of stashing them
in like a like a vault and then feeding
them to some giant like Celestial like
just being like this is how I get rid of
like just feeding them together
just be like putting them on like a like
a satellite and launching them into
Galactic still alive it's just like
stuck in the earth he's like oh you know
you know he's going to TMS
well they could also do the low-key
thing where they could have Head Pool
and dog pool yeah yeah Deadpool squirrel
pull they can expand this out and like I
think the best character for the
Multiverse and the best character to
eliminate continuity issues is one who's
aware that in a comic book yes so I
think that this movie has a lot of
really good opportunity pre X-Men in the
MCU to establish what the Tone's gonna
be and to also eliminate continuity
issues I drank all my coffee there's one
too many cups so I'm gonna take it gets
confusing
the Multiverse cups
gosh sorry it's begun get garage dooring
man here already I've just been drinking
my delicious coffee cult garage door and
I can captured live fleshiana can only
imagine
that's that wrong town did send in a
super jet saying fleshyana is Canon
Cannon she's always the one who's on the
live show the one who's pre-recorded
never fleshyana also this might be some
breaking news coming in Via Super Chat
Dave Owens says simulu was doing a pitch
in a meeting with Ryan the George today
Ryan the George is that okay the George
what do you say John wow
oh like a podcast oh I don't know we
don't believe that Dave I want you you
got more information
Dave call us text us tweet us snap me
yeah it's just my main to wrap up this
discussion really my main thing is just
like I don't I don't see how there could
be like a dead pool that's breaking the
fourth wall so aware in every it'd be
too many of them I agree I love the idea
that there's only one that could be like
also it's not in every continuity that
Deadpool even has that like fourth
ability yeah like it was introduced in
the Joe Kelly run which was like seven
years into his continuity so it's been
like it was that was a good six or seven
years without it and like certain
writers lean into it more there's
there's this really cool run I think
Jerry Duggan where it's different speech
bubbles are different colors so he can
actually talk to his own inner voices oh
so like the square versus the circle
versus the speech bubble versus like
they're different tones so he's got
multiple voices that all interact
simultaneously and some of them are
where he's in a comic some of them
aren't and some of them are where he's
Ryan Reynolds and some of them aren't so
like if they really want to go there
this could be like a voiceover
multimedia multi-art form smash Jazz
grab of movie that sounds like the
writer are screwing over the artists I'm
gonna make this comic book all speech
bubbles yeah
try and draw that
yes
they do every Deadpool loves athletic
greens and I like athletic greens too
whether you're the fleshy version of
yourself or the garage version of
yourself uh you will enjoy athletic
greens and the product ag1 it's an easy
way to get all of your daily nutrition
in one simple drink I like it I drink it
every day it's great I'm not a healthy
person but I drink this and I'd be like
that's great I'm gonna be fine no need
to see a doctor please see a doctor uh
with one delicious scoop of ag1 you're
absorbing 75 high quality vitamins
minerals Whole Food Source superfoods
probiotics and adaptogens to help you
start your day right uh you can drink it
on an empty stomach they recommend that
they're like do that first to cut your
stomach with the goodness let it get in
your body you're gonna have a great
healthy day you're gonna sleep better
you're gonna feel better you're gonna
recuperate better with ag1 you're
getting an all-in-one nutritional
insurance it's much cheaper than
sourcing all of the ingredients yourself
uh that go inside of there don't waste
the time buying each and every
ingredient just get a G1 from athletic
greens it's a small micro habit with big
benefits it's one thing you can do every
single day to take great care of
yourself and they also donate to
organizations when you make a purchase
there it helps them uh get a nutritious
foods to Kids in Need they donate to
operations like no kid hungry right here
in the US so arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition it's just one
scoop and a cup of water every day
that's all you got to do I would
recommend mixing it up too don't just
put the scoop in and drink it it's a
little rough mix it up a little bit to
make it easy athletic greens is going to
give you yes you a free one-year supply
of immune supporting vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com again yes please
that's athleticreens.com break room to
take ownership over your health and pick
up the ultimate daily nutritional
Insurance thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you
um
what's up Tommy it's time
for mandatory fun oh you didn't seem so
sure about that it's time for mandatory
okay okay well they're playing the
graphics uh the graphics is playing so
we must be staying hit that graphic one
more time that's all you got uh no it's
a graphic so right play The Werewolf By
Night black and white photos
that's right it's a graphic so hip we
like to watch it with our pumpkin
sucking lips get my graphic again I do
not like this kind of no unfortunately I
can't host mandatory what Tommy I am so
I'm talking about me going to the horse
funerals and acting
acting my body does maybe the time you
want to handle mandatory funds oh no
I'll go to the horses
I'll try to send someone to sit in my
place okay y'all Talk Amongst yourselves
about when I say the word bird yeah what
kind of bird did you just think tell
Crayola she was a brave man yeah oh okay
horses funny horses in the chat actually
I'm pretty relieved because I killed
this horse okay okay I personally when I
think of birds I think of like a water
bird like I was drinking someone who
does like favors for money
that had a bird in it right there there
you go
wait a second what's happening
Master oh and you this is the quiz okay
the quiz match okay listen the quiz
Master song is a work in progress okay
so I would normally have a top hat but
someone didn't let me know ahead of time
that the quiz Master would be joined all
right this master already chucking
people under the bus
at you all this evening oh okay it's
evening where I am in Vancouver
Vancouver yeah British Columbia uh we
are going
you're going to
all right
are you are you a mutant are you a
powered individual
what what side did you take in the Civil
War I
or questions
uh how did you feel about the
Emancipation Proclamation
that I could have said quiz master in
1939 where could we find you a cafe in
Amsterdam a rally in Germany
uh I have questions for me I have
questions for you I'm sorry I just blew
out my mind probably I was going to ask
you questions and the winner gets some
kind words from the queen kind words you
all can play along and chat but don't
give away the answer so I guess you have
to say the wrong answer I don't know how
that works what are these questions
about question oh that's right
just questions Chris masteries like what
did I have for breakfast right right
what's your death so I can't
honor of the sexual Awakening of shield
and next time it'll be better I promise
you see a dermatologist
things have gone right you've got uh
singular hair your mustache is
generating from your teeth my existence
hurts so honor of the sexual Awakening
get through the sentence you can do it
on some of the real relationship history
of our heroes and villains and Marvel
Comics I'm great don't cry quiz Master
what every team play it's a clementines
quizmaster is a Nexus being for sure
allergic are you having do you want to
just take the mustache off we have a man
stay for it around here somewhere it's a
real mustache I can't take it off
question one okay
oh it just inhaled it and
into
the thin Past comic Gwen Stacy cheats oh
this is a big Downer cheats on Peter
Parker with a Harry Osborne B Flash
Thompson C Matt Murdock or D Norman
Oscar Osborne
because he's already writing is not a
good sign you well I'm sure he knows the
answer you have about I actually know
this three seconds before people get
tired of this character okay we're ready
let's go the answer is D may I see your
white boys I have no idea
I know there were letters I started
writing before okay
yes and then she has a baby
how old is she
next question in the 70s there was a
doctor strange storyline where he and
Cleo went back in time and she hooks up
with what historical figure
hey Abraham Lincoln B Mark Twain C the
sexy Benjamin Franklin you know my
preference or D Cleopatra
oh all right everyone ready I'm waiting
for Brandon to write a big one or one
two three
Benjamin Franklin where's Master curses
I believe you because you said it
because you're you're predisposed notion
will you hook up with Benjamin F the
quiz master has tricks it's a little
tricky bit of a man quiz Master which
side did you take on the French Indian
War in the amazing
things
number
592. Peter Parker returns home to find
Aunt May in bed with whose father
AJ Jonah Jameson that is a name B Mary
Jane Watson C Eddie Brock or D Auto
Octavius I believe Eddie Brock is also
in stranger things didn't she date she
dates autumn
no singing through it
next
next question in the new 52 Catwoman
comics you hear that nerd
and the scene where he keeps where he
keeps on his I didn't write these
questions a cowl B utility belt
spat boots or D all of the above oh you
know what I like best about the quiz
Master no accountability yeah yeah so
have you been keeping track of sports do
you know the score Swiss Masters
what's your answer
I went with seeds just write a [ __ ]
letter nerd God damn it stop showing us
[Applause]
is it just cow bell cowboy boots that's
all so it takes off the pants and the
shirt and the cape yeah right who knows
it might be hard to take off that's true
I hope he has a personality in that
utility bounce okay got him got him next
last last question don't worry
I'm almost gone in All-Star Batman and
Robin the Boy Wonder number seven Batman
hooked with the witch hair heroin on a
burning pile of Gotham Rebel a Black
Canary b zatana c Batwoman or D Wonder
Woman why am I tricking you is it
reverse psychology why did she go wobble
wobble
I want to see what the child has to say
once more the cat's been donating
heavily I think because they think we're
all gonna need help
okay
you all suck even you chat respect your
[ __ ] Elders the answer was a
Blackberry
I got two right I don't think I've got
anything right okay I
know
um
hey John who I've never met before do
you know who won
it's impossible for me to say nice
things
man
hey quiz Master we got a sage this room
we gotta get out of here oh my God
all I know is I don't think we've ever
raised more money during a segment and I
don't know if it was negative or
positive
yeah what happened did you know I ran
into some hottie on the way out but
those horse funerals are [ __ ] fun
dude
they're a bit like Irish wakes and
sometimes they let you ride the corpse
uh well we did get us some super chats
during that match 143 Center Super Chat
I need an hour of quiz Master actually
roasting everyone please can we black
match 143 thank you can we get match 14
Emerson white sang in the mustache group
if the mustache grows from the tip of
your nose I'm not judging but I think
you need to see a doctor that was for
quick if you talk to quiz Master the
mustache is growing we do have some
medical Master believes in doctors uh
house House pass that wrong town said
silent green is Deadpool now I'm a Young
Man uh so I don't know this reference
but I believe as my father would say the
reference is
Soylent
greenering for quiz Master merch in the
chat wow
now while I was passing them I did on my
way out I did see that they were wearing
a detective cap that's not canon
normally they're always seen wearing a
towel they made that point yeah
well they were addressing their their
unhappiness with how much notification I
don't want to see fan art of quiz master
in a detective cap when that is not
Shannon for those of you planning on
making fan art of fleshy quiz Master yep
yeah it should be a top hat not a
detective hat that's garage door where's
the yeah
quiz Master uh Reid Coles was asking uh
do you guys think Loki could be in
Deadpool three I don't think that would
be too shocking if they do a little TVA
action I do feel like those two
characters would vibe yeah
they would Clash like they wouldn't get
along because they would each be trying
to like outwit one another you know
there's a whole uh subplot I think it
was like four or five years into
Deadpool continuity where Loki convinced
Deadpool that he was like the son of
Thor and then Loki also like went
through an existential crisis of who he
was and that led to Christopher priest
run where we first got the notice that
Deadpool is aware someone was writing
him so he like looks out at the page and
he's like someone's writing the story
right now and it all came from Loki god
of Mischief shattering his reality I
highly recommend it I love it uh Jorge
Hernandez dollars was asking well
werewolf By Night get more shows or
movies I mean based on the hype it's
been getting and like the critical
reception I think we're gonna see more
werewolf finite in the future I don't
know what happens in the movie if he
dies or not but I don't even know but I
I guarantee there's gonna be more
monsters more of that stuff uh and
that's a good news considering the
universal monster movie universe
Tom Cruise
[Applause]
they made a Benicio del Toro was in a
wolf man movie that was gonna be part of
it oh man but uh Russell Crowe was there
to collect the Avengers Maui Zeus wasn't
there
uh uh how's the wrong town also as a
Groot pumpkin head crossover when I
don't like all these scary things
I don't know I don't know
um
[Music]
thanks so much for the shout out a few
days ago can I get one for my boy and
two girls you all are the best
absolutely not let's get
let's converters
there's no circumstances will we be
shouting out Roberto M's boy or two
girls we will no Circle we will not be
shouting them out we will not be telling
them thank you for watching the break
room we will not be telling them that
we're glad that they join us every day
we will not be telling them how much we
appreciated that will not be said no we
will not tell them that the secret word
Is lima beans and that is the Awakening
word one day you will not join our army
I must kill the president who said lima
beans
uh uh don't don't clip that out please I
don't I don't want to go to jail
let's put that on Tick Tock Ben Enoch
asks anyone else want to see Shia
LaBeouf as Dr Doom
I think it might be a cannibal he might
be a real life Doctor Doom yeah running
around out there causing Doom wherever
he goes I don't know he's like a
Catholic priest now is it yeah I think
he did a movie and he fell in he fell in
fell in hard welcome to the clinic
is Louise
definitely strike us uh if you're here
live this episode will not exist on the
channel I don't like this episode
Rochester rep 585 That's My Boy Miami
Dolphins gonna get absolutely smoked
tonight by the Bengals you heard it here
first bang bang you're still trying to
prove that this is live yeah
with today's sports scores uh it is true
it is true um we want to thank you all
for joining us today uh apologies to
Android we don't have time to get to
that today but this week's episode was
great as always uh we were also going to
talk a little bit about Black Panther
wakanda forever maybe we'll talk about
that more tomorrow but just so if you
don't know out there the tickets are
expected to go on sale this coming
Monday so we probably think there's
going to be like a new trailer
associated with that Marvel's pattern is
usually teaser trailer full trailer uh
last minute Trail right before the movie
comes out so like
yeah yeah so like please
show them everything show them doctor
I give them to him uh but maybe we'll
talk about that some more tomorrow but
we hope you've enjoyed being with us
here today our thanks to the quiz match
yeah our thanks to the quiz Master for
really taking us down a few pegs uh
thank you to everyone for being on the
show today thank you for being out there
for watching if you haven't hit that
like button go ahead and uh hit that
like button for us join the Discord
where you can comment you can send clips
of the week you can do all that good
stuff uh and you know have a great rest
of your Thursday please we insist uh if
you're not already subscribed to the
channel make sure you subscribe to the
channel I'm giving it a time to draw a a
cute little photo for you all a photo
draw a photo uh but please enjoy the
rest of your Thursdays have a great
evening see us back here tomorrow right
here on the break room
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]